Bella a tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a
questo nuovo nuovissimo episodio di Sons
of the forest Sono veramente contento
ragazzi che vi stia piacendo così tanto
perché a me sta divertendo tantissimo Mi
sembra di essere tornato soldino giovani
di cosa si parla di maestro video
andiamo andiamo avanti andiamo avanti
dimmi te se devo entrare nelle caverne
per per salvarmi il culo Madonna
proseguiamo e L'obiettivo è trovare una
pala la pala ci dà accesso a tutto il
resto del gioco quindi ehm
Paradossalmente è l'oggetto più utile
che possiamo trovare Let's go ragazzi
Vero della roba
c'è un Boh ma lo posso usare no Peccato
però qui e poi vabbè ci sono un miliardo
di caverne quindi è che ne so io porca
[__]
No no non spegnere luce esterna
L'obiettivo non è combattere L'obiettivo
non è ingaggiare gente ragazzi porca
vacca Oh
Arrivederci non pensavo che mi avrebbero
beccato la così lontano ragazzi via via
via via dovevo salvare la partita
ragazzi non ho salvato sono un demente
se muoio sono è finita
Che cazzo è
Ragazzi c'è qualcosa di rosso qua non so
se è positivo negativo
eh eh bene cioè male eh che faccio
pistola stordente oh oh
merda l'ho preso l'ho preso l'ho preso
pistola sotto Ho trovato una pistola
assorbente ragazzi Non chiedetemi
bambini morti via me la sono cavata
abbastanza non so dove sto andando raga
però è quello il problema
c'è uno squalo Addirittura mi chiama
veramente Ah forse mi devo immergona Ma
c'è uno squalo nelle caverne Raga ma
veramente
autorespiratore collected Sì sì posso
buttarmi è il momento di fare fuori lo
squalo ragazzi il momento no no merda
merda usciamo vai vai vai vai vai vai
vai vai vai vai vai veloce probabilmente
stiamo accedendo in una parte dove ci
sono cose segrete perché effettivamente
è un passaggio per niente scontato da
fare questo che sto facendo ok
Mo esco che son fuori dalle e lo sapevo
lo sapevo lo sapevo sono uscito
Porcaccia vacca che giro Kelvin lo vedo
Ma questo Cristiano qua è ovunque Che il
vino che cazzo fai qua e quindi ragazzi
la prima mappa è cioè la prima caverna
No dai non è la prima Vabbè vabbè avete
capito Ragazzi sto gioco è pazzesco Cioè
veramente gigante Il problema è che non
ho il motorino
Ah vedi che ti viene lei se non fai
niente Ah ok Ah si stronzi sei stronzo
però
fottiamone e andiamo via andiamo dalla
c'è un altro bunker laggiù in fondissimo
proprio cioè io vado eh che c'è il
bunker Ok ragazzi teoricamente ci siamo
Eccolo il Caddy lo vedo e qua ci
dovrebbe essere l'altra caverna Dimmi
che non è sotterrata pure que Porca
[__] si indigeni Maledetti Oh che cazzo
c'ha
Magari ha le braccia ma che schifo
Grazie Vabbè comunque qua è sotterrata
porca [__] che palle che palle sta cosa
della Pala Oh Dovunque vado C'è roba
sotterrata Non ha senso ci siamo raga e
col Caddy e anche qua è da dissotterrare
mi sa Eh vediamo
ma che oh oh oh
Ahia puzza che male mai no maglia porca
male Eh ma sei grosso eh [__] tu
Ma porco Dio
Minchia ma è grossi Ma ragazzi Ma chi
cazzo sono Minchia che botta Scusa io
volevo guardare Ah e vattene a [__]
Vabbè io ero io volevo guardare un
attimo che me l'hai fatto Scusa mi ha
fatto fuori subito
Oddio Che succede Sono morto è la prima
volta che muoio Eh non so che succede
giorno
No ragazzi non mi fate girare le palle
Eh che io qua Faccio fuori tutti
che sta facendo Sta pregando Ok Mi ha
seccato proprio quella era veramente
grosso Oh che tra l'altro è lì che sta
facendo sta cacando invece di fare i
gargarismi potreste staccarmi da dove
sono Ecco qua
c'avevo il coltello posso farlo
attenzione
sa che ti
Yes
attenzione che adesso si girano tutti
tipo
a recuperare lo zaino e dove cazzo
Eccolo ragazzi Vi chiedo umilmente scusa
e mi levo dai [__] no E non sarei
tanto a prendere lo zaino ma muovere il
culo io Grazie arrivederci bene Eh ciao
Orca [__] ciao ciao ragazzi è stato
un piacere No veramente terribile
un'esperienza terrificante non lo
rifarei io sappia in the forest hai una
possibilità di morire senza perdere
tutto che è quella Quindi me la so già
giocata però ne è valsa la pena Proviamo
a vedere se la caverna ci dà
soddisfazioni questa qua di fianco
perché effettivamente l'unica caverna
buongiorno Salve salve No non la voglio
cagare signore facciamo quello che vuole
entro un attimo solo per vedere se trovo
medicinali subito in partenza perché
roba che serve qua teoricamente le
caverne mi hanno controllate tutte sennò
il gioco non si finisce e L'obiettivo è
trovare sta [__] Pala maledetta Cioè
se non trovo sta Pala Ok C'è una corda
no no no no no no no no no no no no no
no
Buongiorno Ho sbagliato tutto almeno è
allegra sta caverna Comunque tu sei qua
bombola di ossigeno attenzione Porca
vacca Ah Vuoi vedere che qua con le
bombole lo sapevo lo sapevo c'è un
abisso hanno messo 62 bombole d'ossigeno
per farcelo capire giusto giusto tanto
Son pieno Minchia raga ma dove si va a
guardare gli inferi ci vado con dignità
comunque perché sono entrato tanto sono
entrato a cazzo completamente senza
senso made in Canada notate adesso sta
roba che la bambola è meglio Si vabbè ma
qua ci arrivava anche a Motor Porca
[__] che c'ha Mi scusi ma le pare
questo il motivo Il modo Porca [__]
scherzavo eh fratello però se devi fare
il bagno e fatelo che sai nuotare che
questa non è uno stile nuovo questo lo
stile del morto Questa è la rovesciata
di Ronaldo ragazzi è morto non ci credo
che è morta così entrati
in acqua Vabbè io io non ho fatto eh non
ho fatto niente io eh Cioè è morto da
solo è morto da solo lo giuro
vedi che si ammazzano tutti così eh non
si sprecano neanche i colpi Guarda eh oh
ah ah [__] eh volevate nuotare dovresti
imparare da Dio santo Ma quanti cazzo
sono raga no raga Muoiono tutti così
Mmm Oddio
raga Sono sono sono un killer pazzesco
cioè si buttano in acqua e Muoiono tutti
Mi sa che qua un colpo lo spreco raga 2
Minchia che mira di merda Ok Tanto li
puoi scuoiare questi
e che ci fai
armatura inquietante Collection cos'è
l'armatura in cui no vabbè ragazzi
Questa è nuova eh armature inquietante
collected Vabbè armature inquietante
indossamela proprio indossare ma sto
male che è bellissima Sono entrati una
caverna completamente
Random in tutto ciò
oh oh piano piano piano piano
dove vado cos'è e Gardaland
giorno
C'è un tizio morto Aspetta che dove
cazzo son finito Raga non posso più
uscire devo trovare un'altra uscita Beh
bene trovare un'altra uscita
Granata Collect no Granata Collection
c'è gente raga [__] merda Che palle
provando giù giù giù giù la torcia ok
piano raga è piano piano che c'è gente
qua sono armato fino ai denti e volendo
potreste
non me lo faccio ripetere raga Minchia
oh
160 Oddio
questi qua me li scoio vivi poi prendo
l'armatura ragazzi vado quanti sono
E quanti cazzo siete non seccati 2000 Eh
vabbè quindi non è male però a sto punto
veramente usavo la granata
finito
raga li Sto squagliando tutti Vabbè in
teoria adesso mi posso mettere tutte le
armature qua vediamo
Minchia sono full armatura inquietante
Non lo so
Porca [__] c'è gente
stavolta non ingaggio mica No ragazzi
perché non ho più proiettili corri corri
corri
Oddio
Corri forte
Minchia eh vabbè no ragazzi Qua è pieno
bambini morti e non posso più correre
non posso più correre di correre però
devi correre Anch'io sono Mori sono Mori
corri fratello
Ok fratello devi correre Ti ricordi di
ricorrere non ho poi non correre devi
correre devi correre Uh non lo posso
neanche lutare ragazzi via via via via
ancora un po' ancora di sotto Già son
bagnato e ho freddo pure No vabbè raga
Terribile È terribile sta cosa
è mo' gli chiedo il cazzo raga No no
volete fare un bagno no che so che a voi
piace cit
è morto è morto è morto Bene ragazzi
bagnetto gratis [__] a me Ah se sto
sott'acqua si ammazzano se sto
sott'acqua si ammazza Oh ragazzi trick
sbloccato la Favij eh attenzione
ricordatevi di me lo so sott'acqua
muoiono ma anche lo zio muore sott'acqua
Oh lo zio Prova a caricarmi tipo sono
ancora Oh è morto [__] me la suki la
bombola Intendo la bombola che schifo
che è successo raga li ho seccati tutti
tutti dal primo all'ultimo Sono un
fenomeno [__] l'armatura [__] l'armatura
Eccoci qua
armatura inquietante sono bagnato e ho
freddo ma secondo me l'armatura che mi
bagna Santo di Dio ma che è
Ma che è
bambini morti
che corro corro c'è qualcosa raga
merda
c'è gente [__] a Sore No devo fare
fuori ragazzi che qua c'è roba eh
bambini i bambini lascio perdere questi
di secco uno è morto
Che cazzo è Oh
Ma cos'è No ragazzi
[Musica]
no Raga non sto capendo c'è una musica
incredibile Non sto capendo più di colpi
Vabbè perfetto c'ho solo il taser merda
merda merda e poi inteser non serve un
cazzo raga perché è morite
è morto Beh è utile Intesa con questi
comunque Eh porca [__] ragazzi Beh
sembra che non si muovano però eh finché
non si muove oh oh
Aiuto c'è la palla ce la fa non trova ce
l'ho ce l'ho l'ho trovata incredibile mi
fa andare di là Cos'è sto male
devo correre via allora non vado Non ho
trovato trovato proprio non ci vado Non
ci vado Va bene non mi faceva andare di
là Ho trovato la palla Fermi tutti come
faccio a usci' non ho colpi Non ho nulla
Devo solo uscire raga devo solo uscire
non so come poi tra l'altro perché Porca
[__] non posso uscire perché sono
arrivato con la discesa di Gardaland
No no raga è finita Sono morto che
faccio vai vai vai vai vai vai vai vai
vai vai Oh mio Dio ma non c'era tutta
sta gente prima
cos'è
Ah c'è uno di quegli stronzi lì ma
di là si può andare poi a Forse ho
trovato un'altra ragazza forse c'è
un'altra persona a posto forse c'è un
altro passaggio eh Raga non lo so
briko ho trovato altre granate Ah sì le
grate per lui Minchia ma pensa teu
Madonna raga Sto malissimo Non ho sete
tutto sono morto c'è un'altra via Spero
che i bambini morti
Spero che porti all'uscita raga eh Dove
sto andando dove vado Fatemi uscire
bambini aiuto
non ci credo
ci sono uscita
sono uscito non ci credo No ragazzi
Fermi sono uscito non sto male
ce l'ho fatta due sono dove cazzo sono
sono
c'è Kelvin c'è quasi casa mia Qua vicino
ci posso arrivare adesso che ho la pala
posso andare a dissotterrare il tizio
che sicuramente avrà la tessera 100%, ce
l'ho fatta
Grazie per i tasti permanenti No perché
mi sono sempre serviti nella vita Oddio
ce l'ho fatta Minchia è stato
terrificante Fatemi salvare la partita
perché veramente io non so come ho fatto
Save game Madonna Minchia è stato
terribile raga terribile Fatemi dormire
questo non dorme la sei giorni no
Ma che cazzo è diventato inverno ma
veramente Ma perché cambiano le stagioni
pure a casa mia madonna raga sto gioco
sta diventando complicatissimo Cioè ma
non può essere Vai facciamo un fuoco a
Kelvin tutto ma chi è il bimbo Dov'è
finito avete notato che negli ultimi due
episodi Kevin non esiste Cioè è sparito
gliene frega più cazzo a Kevin Allora
relazione militare ce ne magnamo due
ed è fatta uno e due Let's go vado a
mangiare vado a bere
che manca solo qua Salve quello è uno
dei Giganti forse ragazzi porca [__] mi
serve una pistola un taser una bomba
tieni ti regalo questa
auguri Oh merda
eh gliela Devo lanciare più vicino però
proviamo
penso che abbia funzionato ragazzi eh
Allora bevi Innanzitutto Comunque
ragazzi mi devo prendere la borraccia Eh
perché io veramente Eccola qua
Vai riempie riempi la borraccia
olè Allora raga visto che adesso c'è la
neve io teoricamente Madonna quanto
faccio schifo io potrei farmi
Teoricamente la slitta la slitta me la
potevo fare in quel bunker lì dell'altra
volta se riesco ci ritorno perché con la
slitta teoricamente vado più veloce
avere la neve a questo punto è un plus
se posso usare la slitta per muovermi
bunker questo qua mi raccomando adesso
abbiamo la pala manca solo la tessera se
abbiamo la tessera possiamo accedere a
qualsiasi posto quindi teoricamente
possiamo andare a finire il gioco sto
gioco ragazzi l'abbiamo giocato bene è
andata di culo Anche perché ho trovato
le cose giuste al momento giusto però è
andata bene voglio dire che è Run raga
Ok Eccola qua ragazzi Let's Go inside
Kelvin come sempre se ne sta fuori
Eccoci Minchia mi ricordavo Meno male
ragazzi perché ci sono 26 bunker eh
refill di resina non devo sbagliare
slitta 1000 di resina Let's go questo mi
sta stampando una una [__] slitta
raga Cioè ma sto male Andiamo devi
stamparmi pure la tessera a sto punto Ma
non è che è qua la tessera dello stronzo
io no vabbè slitta slitta stampata con
lettere non ho idea di come funzioni
ragazzi con un altro discorso ora che
abbiamo la la pala Eh si potrebbe
trovare la tessera in due luoghi
il più gettonato in assoluto credo che
sia il posto dove c'è l'altro GPS c'è
l'altro hertag che quello laggiù nel
mezzo c'è un bunker quindi direi di
provare a vedere il bunker posso dire
che secondo me è aumentata la difesa
Bravo bravo questo Ma che bello ma che
cazzo di slitta è una Supa ma non è una
canoa Ma sei scemo Iolo
Beh è utile la scritta comunque
stai Non urlare che mi dai fastidio Chi
è c'è un bordello gigante ovunque
praticamente Ho aumentato la difficoltà
ci siamo raga Eccoci qua dove cazzo son
finito Eccolo
a posto eh seppellisco anche te dopo
Eh
mi dispiace Zia guarda so come fare come
fare una soluzione eh Questa è la
soluzione è molto semplice in realtà Eh
frate
non ho più
colpirla sto stronzo qua o sta qua due
ore uno due
ma me lo fa di sotterrare sul serio
minchia
Oh
no raga è meglio è meglio c'è un fucile
a pompa Grazie frate Ah aspetta intanto
prendo il localizzatore Ok perfetto
lo testiamo
scusi è un test
Beh figo è un test eh Signore scusi
[__] de tu madre
gli è saltata tutta la testa Vabbè io me
ne vado non voglio sprecare colpi per
voi grazie Va bene raga Sono contento
sono contento potete andare peggio E tra
l'altro è l'unica arma che posso
utilizzare adesso perché è la pistola è
andata a farsi [__] A meno che non mi
si ricari Ogni tanto mi si ricarica Devo
trovare il bunker quello sotterraneo
punto cioè quello questo devo fare non
c'è niente c'è un bunker tra tutti
quanti che sotterraneo lo devo
disseppellire con la pala allora
è il momento raga il momento qualcosa
sta uscendo fuori eh ma non capisco
cos'è
è un Bunker Per forza deve essere Eccolo
lì adesso lo vedo Oh
Dio ce l'ho fatta Madonna raga sto
morendo
ma intense Ah manutenzione a entriamo
Vediamo che succede picchia per arrivare
qua raga Madonna oh è chiusa si apre Ah
no si apre Minchia ci manca solo quello
vattene a [__] Vediamo che succede
Raga siamo nel punto dove si deve
proseguire nel gioco eh Viber electrics
c'è Justin Bieber nel mondo di the
forest è un elettricista vedo che
comunque un po' di corrente Salve
buongiorno
Vedo gente vedo che è saltato Qualcuno
si sta muovendo qualcosa ragazzi Twenty
One Pilots qua
Ma che cazzo è Raga raga dove siam
finiti Ok
magnate questo va bene notate la carne
nel frigo forse è andata male ma me ne
fotto si può staccare La musica mi dà
fastidio copertina di album collected
Bad pinet bellissimo grazie della musica
Ragazzi ho capito l'ho visto il vinile
puoi anche toglierlo va bene
e quindi
cos'è
mirino laser con l'exted che puoi
stampare qua le stesse cose vabbè e
niente di che tessuto tecnico
[Musica]
bravissimo carlanter Carlo piantatore
quindi ragazzi l'episodio di salsas of
the forest di Today finisce qua in
questo episodio siamo andati avanti in
un modo pazzesco rispetto agli altri
quindi abbiamo fatto un sacco di
progressi Spero che vi stiate divertendo
perché a me state divertendo un sacco e
ci vediamo nel prossimo episodio con la
tessera ovviamente possiamo fare di
tutto ma non vi spoilero nulla se vi è
piaciuto lasciate un commento mi piace
iscrivetevi al canale e noi ci vediamo
come sempre al prossimo video bella
ragazzi